we came here to watch
on how is the protest in America
we are interested in the protest movement on
to the whole world if we know that somewhere this
happens and we find ourselves there of course
can not keep out and particular today
Russia was also a big process not
can you 30,000 people against the war
Ukraine when it was a peace march
organized by our friends and
propaganda filed everything in such a way that
give them came but actively followed
so what happens there and passed came
a very large number of people we are happy
that they have succeeded and so are we
glad to see a peaceful protest here
without falling down the police as it happens with us
In Russia, for example, I hope that this is the case.
will continue until
option airliner